welcome back to cbs mornings here at 7
30 the car rental giant hertz is under
new pressure this morning in part for
the alleged false arrests of its own
customers stories we've been telling you
about for months now are consumer
investigative correspondent that's anna
werner has spoken to multiple people who
say their lives have been upended by
hertz's actions and now senator richard
blumenthal citing cbs news reporting has
written a letter to the company's ceo
demanding it quote take immediate steps
to remedy the problems for customers
anna werner joins us now anna just a
wild wild story and it continues good
morning
good morning that's right senators are
turning up the heat on hertz even as
more people are coming forward to say
they too had encounters with police
after renting a car from hertz
sir
are you in that nissan with uh yes sir
the man being put in handcuffs is a
former federal law enforcement officer
you're just being detained you
understand
he was on a business trip in oklahoma
city on may 9th of last year he says
when he stopped at a convenience store
he doesn't want his name used because he
used to work undercover but told us one
of the officers approached me and asked
me is that a say your car out that white
vehicle out there yours and i said yes
sir it's a rental car he'd rented the
car from hertz just a few hours earlier
but police told him the car was reported
stolen much to my surprise i end up in
the back of the police car so he pulled
up his hertz rental agreement on his
phone and handed it to the officer
still not good enough
well i'm trying to see where the
the actual car is that shows this
specific car i was getting frustrated
because we've been at this for probably
more than 30 minutes his frustration
boiled over he says in a sarcastic
comment to the officer
i'm sorry
i made that email up tonight which
resulted in this exchange because i can
book you into the worst county jail in
the entire united states right now just
based on me watching you leave that car
and it being reported as stolen just
like that okay and that's a felony
charge you'll have to bond out on
i apologize but then the officers
contacted hertz turns out nine months
earlier hurts had reported the car
stolen but then got it back before
renting it out to him another officer
comes back leans over the window and
tells the officer he didn't steal this
vehicle this guy did not steal this
vehicle correct
hertz told us it did notify police the
car had been recovered but the car was
still listed as stolen in the national
police database leading to what this
former officer says was a potentially
dangerous situation you have police
recovering cars for hurts i mean this is
crazy officers can get hurt first
responders can get hurt and then you're
talking about the safety of officers and
the safety of the general public it's a
concern one former hertz manager agrees
with daniel stokes says he was arrested
at his house in 2006 after renting a car
from his own company they looked in the
garage they looked up and down the
street
asking me drilling me where's the car
where's the car
car's not here i said i returned that
vehicle close to a year ago he says he
was handcuffed in front of his daughters
daughters are upset trying to figure out
what's going on to their dad
it was
pretty traumatic especially traumatic
for stokes because he says he had spent
nearly 13 years working for hertz
including as a manager overseeing 24
branches in the las vegas area he told
us theft reports were filed too often
why do you say that because
it's not actually a theft they still
know where the vehicle is they still can
find the vehicle that's the frustrating
part to me
these are more collection issues than
than theft issues they're not committing
a crime they're not stealing their car
essentially is what you're saying they
have no intent of stealing the car and
nor did he he says he later paid her 750
restitution for the late rental return
and the court dismissed charges filed
against him now members of congress are
calling out hurts in this letter to the
white house competition council
concerning the rental industry overall
senator elizabeth warren cited the
disturbing pattern of customers being
repeatedly arrested and cited multiple
cbs news reports and yesterday senator
richard blumenthal sent this letter to
hertz's new ceo stephen sher demanding
hurts swiftly correct course and ensure
that its customers are not ensnared in
legal battles first you have an
obligation to correct the record to take
action to remedy this wrong to provide
people
some kind of compensation and to admit
that you've done wrong all that after
seeing cbs news reporting the reporting
here has been so powerful
and important because it has revealed
a practice
a
pattern of wrongdoing that is absolutely
staggering
well hertz in response says it takes
these matters seriously and is reviewing
the letters in a statement it said as it
relates to the claims made against the
company we're committed to doing right
by our customers while also continuing
to protect and defend against activities
intended to cause harm to hurts now in
regard to daniel stokes he says he was
out on disability at the time of his
arrest and a year later hertz fired him
in part citing those charges which were
then later dismissed hertz told us it
doesn't have any records retaining or
pertaining that is to the stokes matter
gail
anna it gets more fantastical the more
you tell the story i feel badly for mr
stokes who's arrested in front of his
daughter that had to be very tough for
him and for her and then the former law
enforcement officer i really admire him
you could tell that he was in control
you could also tell he was very
irritated but he knew exactly how to
handle the situation this is scary stuff
anna
yeah she
sorry there is a bit of a delay and yes
and and gail when you talk about scary
stuff that's the thing that we hear from
a lot of these um customers who many of
them were arrested at gunpoint by police
were terrified
and didn't and they don't know what's
happening so in that situation you have
you know here's a former police officer
who understands the protocol but for a
lot of these people this is a surprise
they don't know what's happening and in
those situations things can happen
things can go wrong and that's one of
the things he was saying was look it's
not just the people being arrested it's
the officers too
exactly anna thank you nothing like a
good old satellite delay i always say
they need to get the hertz needs to get
the avis slogan we try harder need to
work on that thank you very much